to terms that you've likely heard in the
context of government spending and
budgets and borrowing are the terms
deficit and debt and they can get a
little bit confusing because they're
associated with borrowing and budgets
and spending and they both start with D
and they are related but they mean
different things a deficit is a
situation where you spend more than you
are taking in so from a government point
of view this would be a situation where
a government spends more in a year then
they take in in revenue in that year so
in in a year or a budgetary cycle
spending more spending more than taking
in and that difference the amount that
you are overspending that year is going
to be a deficit a debt on the other hand
is the total amount that you owe so
total amount amount owed now these are
clearly related let's say in let me make
a a hypothetical government here so
let's say year 1 year 2 year 3 year 4
I'll go up to year 5 and let's think
about the deficit the deficit each year
and let's think about the debt each year
so let's say in year 1 our hypothetical
country we overspend by 200 I'll do
everything in billions of dollars so we
overspend by 200 billion dollars we run
a two hundred billion dollar deficit
well assuming that the debt was zero
before that we're now going to opie 'pl
200 billion dollars I'm assuming
everything here is in billions all right
so let's say the next year we run a
deficit of a hundred billion dollars
well now we owe the money that we owed
before plus another hundred billion
dollars so this would be three hundred
billion and then you
see where this goes if in year three we
run another deficit of let's say let's
say we spend a lot this year a lot more
than we take in so we have a deficit of
500 billion well then that will just add
to our debt so it's going now going to
be 800 billion and of course you can pay
down debt in order to pay down debt you
would run a surplus in a year which you
could view as a negative deficit so
let's say that this year it's negative
100 so normally people wouldn't say this
is a negative 100 billion dollar deficit
normally they would say that the
government ran a hundred billion dollar
surplus but let's say they run that
surplus they pay down the debt well so
now they would pay it down so now we're
we owe seven hundred billion and of
course you could have a year where you
have a completely balanced budget you're
not running a surplus or a deficit and
in that case your debt would stay the
same now some of y'all might be
wondering about the interest but the
interest on the debt that would be part
of the budget so we thought about that
already on whether we're running a
surplus or a deficit to make this a
little bit more clear in the context of
the United States here is a chart that
shows the total deficits and surpluses
for the United States from the late
1960s all the way to near the present
time but then it projects out a decade
and these projections you should always
take with a grain of salt whenever these
bars are going downwards those are years
in which our government is running a
deficit the years where we are above the
line those are where we are running a
budget surplus where the government
actually took in more than it spent so
big picture deficits and surpluses are
talking about how much you are over or
under spending in a given year while
debts are talking about your accumulated
amount that you owe and to make that
clear we can take a look at the total
public debt in the United States and
this once again goes from the 1970s all
the way to near the present and you can
see that the debt has accumulated in a
pretty big way it's approaching this
says 20 million but you have to look at
this it says millions of dollars so this
is 20 million
or 20 trillion dollars of debt this is
how much the United States government
owes but some of you might argue that
hey look the economy has grown a good
bit so what really matters is how much
do you owe as a percent of GDP so this
shows as a percentage of GDP it's not
quite as dramatic but our government
debt is now about equal to our annual
GDP so if you were to make an analogy to
your personal life if you say made
$100,000 in a year this is like having
also $100,000 of debt now an interesting
question is what are the pros and the
cons of running a deficit in a given
year which is going to add to the debt
well some of the arguments in favor of
sometimes running a deficit which will
add to the debt is that it allows a
government to do counter-cyclical fiscal
policy or if you're into a recession to
have an expansionary expansionary fiscal
policy which we've talked about in other
videos often involves maybe lowering
taxes and increasing spending and that
could allow the government to maybe make
a recession less severe which might
allow everyone to be better off in the
long run and these things are all
debated now the cons are easier to think
of one could imagine that at some point
the debt becomes unsustainable debt
unsustainable and there are definitely
examples of other countries that have
run such large debts that they could not
even service the interest just remember
whether it's just you individually or
government when you borrow money you
have to pay interest at some point the
interest could become so significant
that the government can no longer afford
to pay it and even if a government can
pay the interest on the debt that money
that's being used for interest could
have otherwise been used for other
things another con of running large
deficits which could lead to large
accumulated debts
that it can affect interest rates in the
broader market so you could lead to an
increase increase in interest rates
interest rates when we studied the money
market we would see that hey the more
that the government is out there trying
to borrow money that's going to shift
demand in the money markets to the right
and if the interest rates increase that
could lead to what we've talked about
before the idea of crowding out or the
crowding out effect where because of
increased interest rates fewer potential
private borrowers are going to go and
borrow money which they might use to go
out and invest things so those are these
are all very interesting things to think
about but the big takeaway here is to
not get confused between deficit and
debt deficits and surplus to how much
you are over or under spending in a
given year debt is the total amount you
owe